So yesterday with Michael Bloomberg first
debate as the democratic presidential candidate
here
finally got the polling support that he needed
in order to get into a debate. Now that of
course the DNC has eliminated that individual
donor requirement as a prerequisite for getting
into the debates and Michael Bloomberg was
eaten alive. I mean just absolutely annihilated
in what could be a campaign ending debate.
I don't know. It might not be, and we're going
to talk about that a little bit later. Depends
on how many people watched the debate. It
depends how many people are sort of staking
their support on Michael Bloomberg based on
something like debate performance rather than
for other reasons. We'll get to that. We were
wondering will it be the centrists attacking
Bloomberg because he is more of a direct threat
to them. Would it be the Progressive's Bernie
and Warren trying to take advantage of having
a turbo billionaire on the stage to talk about
how radically different their policies are?
And the answer was yes, yes to all of it.
Yes. To all of the above. Everybody attacked
Bloomberg centrists in one way, the Progressive's
in another way. And I'm going to show you
some of those moments now before we do this,
if you had pulled me aside yesterday, five
minutes before the debate and said to me,
David, if you had to guess, do you think Elizabeth
Warren will mention horse faced lesbians in
the first 20 seconds of the debate later in
the debate or not at all? I probably would
have said, I don't expect Elizabeth Warren
to mention Horseface lesbians and I would've
been wrong within the first 20 seconds at
her first opportunity to talk Elizabeth Warren
going right in on Michael Bloomberg with alleged
comments that he's made about women. Take
a look
for another four years and we can't stand
that. So I'd like to talk about who we're
running against. A billionaire who calls women
fat broads and horse faced lesbians. And no,
I'm not talking about Donald Trump. I'm talking
about mayor Bloomberg. Democrats are not going
to win. Just
immediately setting the tone for what was
going to be a night of slamming Michael Bloomberg
without Bloomberg defending himself particularly
well and he was taking hits left and right.
It was nonstop. The worst moment for Bloomberg
was when Elizabeth Warren started pressing
him about nondisclosure agreements with former
employees related to sexual harassment, most
of which we believe, I mean we don't know
cause they're NDA, but we believe most of
it was between other, uh, employees. In other
words, it was at Bloomberg's company but didn't
involve Bloomberg. Although eventually Bloomberg
talks about, you know, jokes I told that people
may not have liked. And, uh, Bloomberg was
not well prepared for this. Uh, really, really
brutal, brutal. And again, Elizabeth Warren
just really destroying him.
Senator Warren even critical available above
on this issue. Yes, I have. And I hope you
heard what his defense was. I've been nice
to some women.
[inaudible]
the mayor has to stand on his record and what
we need to know is exactly what's lurking
out there. He has gotten some number of women,
dozens who knows to sign nondisclosure agreements,
both for sexual harassment and for gender
discrimination in the workplace. So mr mayor,
are you willing to release all of those women
from those nondisclosure agreements so we
can hear their side of the story?
[inaudible] we have a very few
nondisclosure agreements. How many, how many
is that? None of them accused me of doing
anything other than maybe they didn't like
a joke I told and let me just pause and let
me put,
so this is already terrible. I did nothing
other than maybe somebody didn't like a joke
I told. That's terrible. That's a, I couldn't
think of a worse way to try to explain what
happened. Typically jokes don't lead to payoffs
and nondisclosure agreements. It's already
bad for Michael Bloomberg. But let's continue.
Maybe they didn't like the joke I told and
let me just pause and let me put, these would
be agreements between two parties that wanted
to keep it quiet and that's up to them. They
sign those agreements and we'll live with
it. So wait, when you say it, it's up to you.
I just want to be clear. Some is how many
and when you, and when you say they signed
them and they wanted them, if they wish now
to speak out and tell their side of the story
about what it is they alleged, that's now
okay with you. You're releasing them on television
tonight, Senator
[inaudible],
son of a company, and somebody else in this
case, the man or a woman or could be more
than that. They decided when they made an
agreement that they wanted to keep it quiet
for everybody's interests. They sign the agreements
and that's what we're going to live. I'm sorry.
No, the question is, are the women bound by
being muzzled by you? And you could release
them from that immediately, but there's understand
this is not just a question of the mayor's
character.
So just taking shot after shot. And what we
learned yesterday was that Michael Bloomberg
did not make his billions winning any debates.
That's for very sure, a very good analysis
of what happened by brand new CNN, political
commentator, Andrew Yang about Bloomberg's
failure. Uh, here is a Andrew Yang's take
on it.
Yeah. And you know the field the best. You
know what it's like on that stage. What was
the read? I think three things happened to
Mike tonight. Number one, he just found out
he'd make the debate yesterday. There were
two times when I wasn't sure if I was going
to make the debate and my team got me together
to prepare. And you're really not sure if
you're preparing cause you're like, I'm not
sure if I'm going to be in this debate. So
Mike, even though he was, I'm sure getting
coached and prepared, he was like, I don't
know if I'm going to be in this debate. And
so I don't think he was coached hard enough.
Number two, he was clearly instructed to keep
his cool no matter what. But that ended up
presenting as being lethargic and on interested
for a big chunk of the debate. And the third
most telling thing is that if I'm his team,
you know he's going to get a stop in the first
question like, uh, uh, gender discrimination
or mistreatment question. So you coach him
and you have him give you 60, 75 second answers
over and over again until he can do it in
his sleep. And the fact that he did not have
those answers at his fingertips, let's me
know categorically he was not properly prepared
for this debate.
Now I could go on with the Bloomberg stuff,
but it's all this bad. Before we move on,
if you want to say what good moments did Bloomberg
have? A, I think his best moments were at
one point there, there was a debate about
whether it should be mandatory that employees
be given 20% ownership of the companies where
they work. And Bloomberg said, guys, this
isn't going to happen and it helps Trump that
we're even talking about this. And I tend
to agree with him there. We want to democratize
the workplace. There are countless ways to
do at work or representation on boards tying,
you know, the, the multiple of the CEO wage.
There's all these different things we can
do. A law that mandates 20% ownership is turned
over to employees. It's just not happening
anytime soon. And making it a subject of debate,
uh, pushes people away, uh, from any Democrat
I believe. And here is Michael Bloomberg making
that point.
Oh, so they can have some say of what happens
to their lives. A large company. Would you
support what Senator Sanders is proposing?
Absolutely not high. Can't think of a ways
that would make it easier for Donald Trump
to get reelected and listening to this conversation.
It's ridiculous. We're not going to throw
out capitalism. We tried that. Other countries
tried that. It was called communism and it
just didn't work. So let me make a proposal
that will work, that has not only support
from then,
uh, at another point, uh, Michael Bloomberg
also, uh, talking about, uh, as you mentioned
there, the, the communism thing, that's a
total red herring and it doesn't make any
sense to mention that we're not talking about
communism here. Bloomberg is right that a
debate about forcing companies to give 20%
of their ownership away is a, right now the
communism comment is just dumb. One other
moment that was sort of okay for Bloomberg,
although it ended up falling flat, was bringing
up this tired old thing about Bernie's three
houses.
It's a wonderful country. We have the best
known socialists in the country, happens to
be a millionaire with three houses. What I
miss here, well, you'll miss that. I work
in Washington. Pouts watch the first prop
live in Burlington house toad. That's good.
And like thousands of other Vermonters. I
do have a sub, a cap to give to me for that.
Whatever is your home, which talks where it's
tax Haven, New York, New York city. Thank
you very much. I pay for my tax.
So I don't know. I mean maybe by some standard
it was okay for Bloomberg, but it was really,
really bad overall. The one thing that Bernie,
that Bloomberg's presence did do was energized
just about everybody on the stage. Even Joe
Biden was fired up in the first part of the
debate. Warren had higher energy. If Biden
had had yesterday's level of energy throughout
the debates, he might not have tanked his
polling the way that it has. The other really
weird dynamic was mayor Pete versus Amy Klobuchar
getting into some very odd exchanges, including
Pete hammering her about forgetting the president
of Mexico's name. Really going hard on that.
And I said that I made an error. Um, I think
having a president that maybe is humble and
is able to admit that here and there maybe
wouldn't be a bad thing, but if you could
let me a response
trivial. I actually didn't know how many members
were in the Knesset, but you're staking your
candidacy on your Washington experience. You're
on the committee that oversees border security.
You're on the committee that does trade. You're
literally in part of the committee that's
overseeing these things and we're not able
to speak to literally the first thing about
the politics of the country to ourselves.
Are you trying to say that I'm dumb or are
you mocking me here, Pete? I'm saying
I made an error. People sometimes forget names.
I am the one that has, number one, has the
experience based on passing over. One thing.
If I could respond, this was a pretty big
allegation. He's basically saying that I don't
have the experience to be president of the
United States. I have passed over 100 bills
as the lead Democrat. Since being in the U
S Senate, I am the one not you, that has won
statewide in congressional district after
congressional district. And I will say when
you tried in Indiana, Pete, to run what happened
to you, you lost by over 20 points to someone
who later lost in my friend Joe Donnelly.
So don't tell me about experience. What unites
us here is we want to win.
I genuinely don't know who that was good or
bad for because it was also weird and Pete
just continuing to go after her on this issue.
All right, and I think we should put a proven
winner and charge of that ticket. This is
a race for print. This is the race for president.
If winning a race for Senate in Minnesota
translated directly to becoming president,
I would have grown up under the presidency
of Walter Mondale. This is different and the
reason that I think we need to talk about
Washington experience is that we should ask
what that experience has led to experiences.
And certainly tenure is not always the same
thing as judgment. We're going to talk about
votes in the Senate in Washington. Let's talk
about [inaudible]
a lot of talking over each other there and
that was another unfortunate theme of the
night candidates and moderators constantly
talking over each other. Many of the candidates
being cut short in their answers. One of the
moderators, Chuck Todd Todd almost constantly
with a running soundtrack of, yeah. Yeah,
and okay. Okay. Over the candidates answers
extremely, extremely annoying. Bernie had
a lot of good moments. For example, this one,
defending workers again in the face of Bloomberg,
the target for the night
to make policy. It is my policy and I'm very
proud of that policy. What we need to do to
deal with this grotesque level of income and
wealth inequality is to make sure that those
people who are working for Bloomberg wasn't
you who made all that money. Maybe your work
is playing some role in that as well. Those
workers are able to share the benefits. Awesome.
When we have so many people go to work every
day and they feel not good about their jobs,
they feel like cogs in a machine. I want workers
to be able to sit on corporate boards as well
so they can have some safe of what happens
to their lives.
Another strong Bernie moment calling out mayor
Pete in sort of clearer, more direct terms
this time about his billionaire or billionaire
donors. Pete visibly sweating during this
moment. When you see the closeup of Pete,
he's sweating badly
if speaking to the needs and the pain of a
long neglected working class is polarizing.
I think you got the wrong work. Well we are
trying finally to do is to give a voice to
people who after 45 years of work are not
making a nickel more than they did 45 years
ago. We are giving a voice for people who
will say we are sick and tired of billionaires
like mr Bloomberg saying huge expansions of
their wealth while a half a million people
sleep out on the street tonight and that's
all we are saying. Jake is maybe a time for
the working class for this country to have
a little bit of power in Washington rather
than your billionaire campaign contributors.
Very, very strong Bernie throughout. I would
probably say Bernie and Warren were the, uh,
last night, um, with, uh, Joe Biden close
behind just showing more energy, uh, than
he has in recent times. Pete and Amy sort
of going after each other on weird things.
And then Bloomberg really the loser of the
night. So if you say to me, uh, who is the,
uh, in the net, who's the biggest winner last
night? I actually believe it's Donald Trump.
Donald Trump net benefited the most from last
night's debate because Bloomberg completely
self-destructed and we'll see what this does
to his campaign. The other candidate has got
shots in it, Bloomberg, but otherwise, I don't
believe the needle will be greatly moved for
anybody else because we're so far into this
thing. And the only new presence on the stage
was Michael Bloomberg and overall the what
will be portrayed as infighting by the right,
even though it was making very clear the different
types of choices that are available.
I think in the net, Trump comes away with
a slight benefit from last night's debates.
Just my opinion and you can disagree with
me and we can all be reasonable, respectful
people on that issue. Did a poll on my Twitter
about 4,000 of you voted. The question was
how does tonight's debate affect Bloomberg's
polling? A plurality, nearly 40% said Bloomberg
loses eight or more points as a result of
last night's performance. I don't think it's
actually that bad, but I do think Bloomberg
loses a bit, maybe has to spend another hundred
million to gain it back. I did not expect
Bloomberg to get as annihilated as he did
last night and one other thought that I had
about last night's debate. Last night's debate
was by far the most entertaining debate of
the primary, but we also probably heard the
least about policy from the candidates. Detailed
policy. It was a lot of attacks on Bloomberg,
Pete and Amy arguing about experience and
how bad it is not to know the name of the
president of Mexico.
You had a lot of talking point attacks. That's
probably in some way emblematic of our politics
and media today. Sadly, the most entertaining
to watch debate whose ratings may have been
very, very good, had the least substantive
policy discussion of any recent debate. I
can remember certainly ideological differences
and draw lines in the sand were drawn, but
maybe in some way this is part of the problem
that we're having in the discourse in the
United States. I guess the major thing we
learned of new information is Michael Bloomberg
is not a good debater. Let me know your thoughts.
Let me know what you expect to be the implications
and repercussions to last night's debate.
I'm on Twitter at the Pacman. They'll take
a quick break
and feedback with much more